野菜1日　これ一本
これを飲めば１日分の
野菜がチャージできるというやつですね
１日の野菜摂取　モウ🐮
え、　う～ん　う～ん　SE『ｸﾞｼｬ』
うん、なるほど
で、今ジュース禁止してるんですけど
これ野菜ジュースというより
あ、ジュースって書いてあるな
こらあ違うこらあ違う
野菜一日これ一本とか濃縮系の
トマトジュースとかね
ジュースと名乗っている　名ばかりのジュースってのがあるんですよ
お下がりのシューズ　わかるか？　お下がりのシューズ
・・・・・・
お下がりのシューズ　（ふざけたごめん）
甘みの少ない野菜ジュースは
僕の中では体にいいものだと思ってるので
ジュースではないという　カウントのもと
今日の動画を撮っていこうと思っております。
はじめしゃちょーDEATH!!!!
SE『ﾋﾟﾆｮ×２』
野菜１日これ一本
これすごいんですよ　30品目の
野菜が入ってるんですよ
で食塩も砂糖も無添加
100％ですよ野菜　じるが
ポンッ（痛い；；） 　これー僕思ったんですけドゥー
果たして！　野菜一日これ
IPPON!　これ一本飲めばいいってことは...
ﾝﾁﾞｮ-ｯﾄﾏﾃwwww 　俺になに言ってんだ？w
でも俺のしたいことはこうです。　野菜１日これ何本
という...企画です。　ﾌﾊwwﾁｮｯﾄww　SE『シェン』
わかんなくなってきたなー
ま、とりあえず何本飲めるかということを
知りたいんですよ　僕は１日のうちに　野菜１日
これ一本っていう　コレ、コレ一本ですよって
掲げてる海水ですよこの会社が（？）
かごめさんが、これ１日１本飲めばいいんですよって
掲げてる所を果たして何本まで飲めるかと
ナンナン日分　何日分のや、野菜さを
取れるかっていう　ちょっと限界に挑んでみようと思います
名付けて！
「..........」
俺これが言いたいだけなんだ
ε≡≡ﾍ( ´Д`)ﾉ
ﾃﾞﾝﾃﾞﾃﾞwwﾃﾞﾝﾃﾞﾃﾞwwﾃﾞﾝﾃﾞﾃﾞww
ﾄﾞｩﾗﾗﾗwwwﾃﾞﾝﾃﾞﾃﾞwwﾃﾞﾝﾃﾞﾃﾞwwﾃﾞﾝﾃﾞﾃﾞww
ﾃﾞﾝ!ﾃﾞﾝ!　ﾃﾞﾝﾃﾞﾝﾃﾞﾝwwﾃﾞﾃﾞﾃﾞﾝww
ﾃﾞﾃﾞwwﾄﾞｩﾗﾗﾗww　ﾃﾞﾝﾃﾞﾃﾞｗｗﾃﾞﾝﾃﾞﾃﾞｗｗ
デン！　　果たして拙者は
１日に何本分の１日分の
野菜をトリ☆＆＊＞？￥　やっていこうと思います
一本目！　SE『ﾃﾞﾃﾞﾝ』
↖にご注目
※はじめ先生のリアクションをお楽しみ下さい。
今の俺じゃないからね！俺じゃないからね今の
チュルチュル
SE『テケテケテケ』　SE『ボヨ～ン』
あぁ美味え　今日何も
食べてないし飲んでないんで　最高に美味しいッス
SE『ｷﾗｰﾝ』
んん～　一本目クリア　二本目　SE『ﾃﾞﾃﾞﾝ』
ゴクゴクはじめん
おえい　　二本目
ｸﾞﾘｱ
ロングブレス
SE『ｼｬﾝ』　やばいぞちょっと思ったよりダメージが凄いな...
３本目　SE『ﾃﾞﾃﾞﾝ』
チュルチュルはじめん
あぁー三本目クリア。。。　これ何mlだ？
２００ml！？　まだ６００か！
やばいな
四本目　SE『ﾃﾞﾃﾞﾝ』
チュルチュルはじめ
チュルはじめ
四本目です...　や、あぁ...
喘ぎはじめん
はぅぅ...　すげぇ...　ちょっとやばい　おっしゃ
根性見せるぞ！　五本目　SE『ﾃﾞﾃﾞﾝ』
チュルはじめ
チュルめ
六本目
ゴキュゴキュはじめ
ゴキュはじめ
ゴキュめ
ﾁｭｰ　ｶｯ
豚（トン）
はい　というわけで一週間分
七本分とりました　あーや
ちょ...あれ....おかC...あぁ...
ﾔｯﾀ...　ｳﾚｼｰﾅｰ（棒）
これで俺は一週間野菜食べなくて
いんだよ.........葉🌿葉🌿葉🌿葉🌿
ﾏﾀﾞｲｸﾞｿﾞｫｰｰ！！　SE『ﾃﾞﾃﾞﾝ』
約６秒間チュルめをお楽しみ下さい。
おけい　SE『ﾃﾞﾃﾞﾝ』
（嫌がりながらもストローを指すイケメンはじめ）
チュルめ（約４秒）
ﾔｰﾁｮｰﾏﾃ　ﾔﾊﾞｲ
あぁ。。　ｱｰﾗｰﾒﾝﾗｰﾒﾝﾗｰﾒﾝｸｲﾃｰ（復活の呪文）
うはぁ　（リズミカルな机叩き）
うぅ..うぅ..うぅ..
まだいけるー！！！　もう一本ぐらい
いける気がする　👃
やべぇ　鼻から
野菜ジュースが出るんだけど　何がおきてるの？
苦しむチュルめ（約４秒）
ﾁｭｰｶｰ
１０本(>_<)！ いややばいよ
１０本って　あの２リットルのコーラ
１本分飲みましたからね今　SE『ﾃﾞﾃﾞﾝ』
１１本いきます
もう一人のはじめ「手が震える...」
チュルめ（約４秒）
はぁ...
ｱｱｱ　モウ🐮
(ｳﾞｯ...)
１１本！
飲みましたー！　すいません！！！
１１本が限界です　ううう；；(泣)
ただ僕はこれで野菜１日これ
１１本飲んだので１１日間は野菜を
食べなくて、良いです（満面の笑み）
(エンディング入ります→ドゥテルテ)
(ドゥテルテ×２)
(ドゥテルテ×２)　トゥー
(ドゥテルテ×２)　トゥルル　トゥートゥー　トゥルル
(ドゥテルテ×２)　トゥー　トゥルル
(ドゥテルテ×２)　トゥートゥー　トゥルル
(ドゥテルテ×２)　トゥー　トゥールル　トゥルル
ルールー　ズタ　ズタ
ズタ　ズタ　ず・た・た・たん♪
これ賞味期限がですね　全部
２０１７年まで持つので
ここに余ったやつは今日から毎日飲もうと
思います。。。
健康だね
モオー！！🐮(>_<)